- [Narrator] This fuzzy
little creature is a quokka.
And these guys live
here off the west coast
of Australia on Rottnest Island.
Quokkas are not only cute,
they are camera ready.
And they're taking the internet by storm.
So, let's start at the beginning.
What is a quokka?
- A quokka is a small wallaby.
It comes from the same
family as a kangaroo.
And physically they've
got thick brown fur,
they've got long tails
and they hop around.
Quokkas thrive on Rottnest Island
because they don't have
any predators over here,
so there's no foxes.
We have the largest viable
population of about 10,000.
- [Narrator] Oh, sorry, and you are?
- My name's Cassyanna Gray,
and I'm a conservation officer
on Rottnest Island.
In my role I'm responsible
for managing conservation programs.
- [Narrator] And there's one online trend
that has really helped these animals.
A quokka selfie.
But make sure you're getting it right.
How to take a quokka selfie.
Step one: a camera.
Step two: a quokka.
- But don't touch the quokkas.
- [Narrator] Ah, no.
- Or feed them.
It's $150 fine.
- [Narrator] These guys
don't need the food.
They naturally graze their way through
the island's vegetation.
- And they also really love
the seedlings that we plant
as part of our re-vegetation projects
that we have implemented by
our environment technicians.
- [Narrator] Sorry about that guys.
Thanks for all your hard work.
And what makes these guys
so great for taking selfies?
- [Cassyanna] Around the
settlement areas the quokkas
are a lot friendlier; they've
become used to people,
so their natural behaviors change.
But out in the reserve
where they're actually still
exhibiting their natural behavior,
they will be a lot more wary of people.
- [Narrator] We have to know,
are they actually smiling in photos?
- [Cassyanna] Yeah, they're
not actually smiling
in the photos, it's just the
natural shape of their mouth,
which comes up at the side,
which makes them look
like they're smiling.
The popularity of the quokka selfie
has given us the opportunity
to be able to raise awareness
about the quokka's
particularly on the mainland
that are under threat.
So we use that as a platform
to educate the public
and also educate them about appropriate
interaction with wildlife.
- [Narrator] So finally,
a good cause for selfies.
(upbeat music)